[音楽]
dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
うーん
それでは今コラボの大好きな断面小説である
金原ひとみの民家を読み上げたいと思います
なんで好き勝手言うと出身校になりきれるというか共感できるからです
ん
ブーバら目の前の男に
がー4敗ている
勢い余って4パットは私は埋まりううううちっ4泊せぬ違うよ
ちょっとり三明この後弊社か重い滑り込み
男は見えなくなった
匹とうとうとて急停車した電車
私は下のとか気になってることないらしく
電車との街道の早期 com 店主の側面に頭のてっぺんをつけるようにしてましたを
覗き込む私の顔がアップになる
っとその時再び急発進した天使
ブーブー no 未曾有サティ4ポート army まぶたの二ぬーんぬー
だしのか
チェーンの脳からこの買ってきた男の眼球と目がお怒りも今これから精神鎧武顔とする
新形状の女性的な単米映画の主人公になったつもりで
さあ待っている私は
実際はプレほど神経症ではない
これはこれくら精神科医の買おうとしている
神経症も女性を演じようという私ど淫靡による
うっそうそうだこの遊びがどこから始まったのかといえば今日こそ
を静止画予約を入れたにもここをする
北高されると音から大瀬戸中を高めている家へ日後のことカオス降ったため
6適用バお嫁どえこうしてしまったところから大目玉 l 列車を待っている男別に
にくくただ
突き落としてみたらどうなるかを注ぐし
貴音したら大変なことになるのだよという自分への警告としている
想像でのあるから電車等とか聞こえる
私は月を取らない
弊社は大前要所に会えて込んだ
本当に強化できる話ですね
ni